[Music]
is that the Phil brought to you by the
Dollar Shave Club a great shave at a
great price conveniently delivered right
to your home
[Music]
I'm crazy haha oh my god Oh Nicolas Cage
I am so Nicolas Cage hot damn you've
just won update 11 I rage and I break
every gauge Nic Cage I'm on a ragin
Cajun craze location on the new LAPD a
PhD cage is my golden age ridiculous
Nicolas Cage nature sorcerer amazing
news my name is wait for it search
[Music]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic I
remember it so you don't have to why do
I keep falling for Nicolas Cage movies
there used to be a time where when he
was good he was amazing and when he was
bad he was still amazing he was one of
the most entertaining people to watch
but then he got into making so many of
them that the cage magic was spread too
thin but was her script over too much
burn it wasn't as much fun anymore
nevertheless I still look forward to
them why because I'm a frigging dumbass
no joke if anyone ever in both of
celebrity and something I like I always
fall for it hello Paul
it's not Oscar me Nicolas Cage I will no
I question this naturally I want you to
join me in Toni Goldmark in the other
room we'll dress like bears and sing
ducktales in Egypt you got it oh by the
way this call is collect cuz I just
collected your dumb ass damn it Tony no
wonder they call you some jerk with a
camera and I got it all on camera oh
great you exploited my very specific
point and it was amazing ah so you flew
all the way out here just for that huh
yeah in hindsight it didn't really
justify the cost
I mean plane tickets gas hotel do you
have a hotel I flipped on the roof Oh
God mind if I stay here until I
crowdfund my way home yeah sure god
bless ya ooh The Sorcerer's Apprentice
you know critic in the course of
reviewing Disney rides I also sometimes
review their movies and other projects
good
Plus in 2010 Nicolas Cage gave up
another dolls after with the sorcerer to
pray all right get over here
she Sorcerer's Apprentice in 1940 Walt
Disney released perhaps his most
audacious experiment in a career of
audacious experiments Fantasia
heralded by some as Walt's masterpiece
combined classical music with classic
Disney animation in ways no one had seen
before and it's most famous sequence is
the Sorcerer's Apprentice starring
Mickey Mouse a simple story about
janitor who almost destroyed the world
it featured the mouse who started it all
in his red robe and blue hat magically
controlling the costumes becoming one of
the most iconic images and Disney the
lustrous history then seven decades
later this presumably happened just that
I want to play a wizard well we can
certainly do that yes we have a live
action version of sword and a stone
Black Cauldron No Wizards of Waverly
Place yeah a wicked style Jafar movie Oh
an all-male hook is pocus reboot I wanna
blow Mickey Mouse what mouse
no yes just run it by my Adrian who says
you have to ever we notice that scars
just gonna be OH
oh man I cannot wait to do her this
lonely that's we got a movie that has
little to nothing to do with The
Sorcerer's Apprentice called
The Sorcerer's Apprentice directed by
Jon Turteltaub you mean the same guy who
directed oh yes
three ninja stars the film was trying to
cash in on hugely successful cinematic
updates of Disney properties at the time
like Pirates of the Caribbean and
Pirates of the Caribbean but where that
movie at least had some connection to
the original source material had a
dancing broom for a minute
authentic let's take a look at where the
magic is gone with Sorcerer's Apprentice
it opens with a prologue so complicated
you'd swear they were trying to squeeze
in five other movies into this movie the
fate of mankind rested with the just and
powerful Merlyn he told his secrets to
three trusted apprentices Balthazar
Veronica and Horvath this is ian mcshane
by the way I figured I'd introduce
myself because I have no idea what
character I'm supposed to be in this
nevertheless I'll still leave a bigger
impact in Pirates whore
Morgana LeFay Merlin's most deadly enemy
well that in transformers 5 he's off but
servants I'm gonna assume that the
different spelling but the way this
movie goes it won't surprise me well in
OMA you betray me
nice read their spirit Halloween store
beard this is why the board queen is
assimilating you
this movies in such a hurry they
dissolve from one shot to the exact same
shot I hate it when movies do this this
was clearly a full scene at one point
but it didn't work so they cut it down
and editing and tried to make it faster
and that's why we should all go to Mitt
Romney's house dressed as hamsters and
convinced him he's a hamster too when
his entire human life has been a dream
well you really went off on a tangent
there Erikson Post
Veronica sacrificed herself for
Balthazar by drawing Morgana soul into
her own body
Balthazar trapped them both in the
Grimhold an inescapable prison that you
can buy at your grandma's antique store
so about this an art play by cage
searches the world for Merlin's
successor the prime merlinean that will
one day defeat the trapped Morgana
but he'll in no way uses powers to stop
the atrocities of history
well mankind will never be safe until
Morgana is destroyed maybe you can use
those powers to stop two world wars if
you have the time slavery genocide those
will sort themselves out he's got to
keep the world safe flash-forward to our
young protagonist being awoken by his
corporate masters heading to school in
me this is David a boy who's so new to
dating that he has a girl out the same
way a girl would ask a girl out yeah
where's the box where I would like to be
David's restraining order but the note
blows away and David chases after it
already done
I guess I could just ask her since she
clearly already knows I wrote it but I
need the receipt for my taxes well he
comes across Merlin's magical shop of
gremlins reading the neverending story
as he looked at all the mysterious
wonders like look at the capitate a
little girls had he literally bumps into
cage who as you would expect is a little
quirky I have something I'd like to show
you doing how do you know my name was
Dave cuz I can read mind
okay movie Nicolas Cage is one of those
people you do not need to over score
yeah he's already his own strange music
a magic ring clings to his hand meaning
he's the chosen one because God knows
why your actions should make you special
he's just chosen other knieval villain
is released as well all this twerp says
skin really knows that vocabulary from A
to A it's not very sporting of you
Balthazar where's that dog topology is I
guess I could have just look down
question two how'd it get burned
how'd it get burned the evil Horvath
played by Alfred Molina manages to fight
cage back I'll have that doll John at
heart heart on a Tartar hi I'm Network a
sparrow
melina throws fire at him only to find
out fire doesn't hurt him so why did he
throw fire in him they both get sucked
into the magic urn and David leaves the
store and coincidentally comes across
his field trip
a Georgia business card
Oh God that kid laughing terrifying
she even somebody so long laughing that
hard bag you leave her alone she's a
good friend of mine
really yeah she grew up into a lovely
woman she just there in silence until
you which is not to me I told you is
that not to question her let's just
continue the review cut to ten years
later where David has grown up into man
seeking plot Jay Baruchel a shame his
voice didn't grow up with him as it
constantly sounds like two geese
fighting over rye bread he lives with
the unsuccessful prototype of Ned and
spider-man homecoming and comes across
an old familiar face I'm sorry yes Becky
Becky Barnes Bucky Barnes hang on I've
always wanted to do this longing rusted
17 Dave hey we were in fourth grade
together in a bizarre twist this is
actually not scary girl I was laughing
at him all those years ago
oh great you got it rolling again what
we do let her laugh result
can we put a blanket on her or something
go ahead you do it he helps her fix the
college radio station she worked at what
care - Malina has a vase cheerio Azam
you'll take me to a lawyer and a stop a
Dresden Files law sir milena finds David
and tried to force him to give him the
Russian doll known as the Grimhold
I'll cut the truth out of you
and at that very moment the word nerve
was created he finally figures out the
sorcery of opening a door and Malina
sends wolves after him though honestly
there's about a billion ways he could
have just kept him in that room but it's
cool cage turns them into puppies okay
if he could turn the Wolves into puppies
how come he come - Malina into a baby
because then he'd have to raise them
with holly hunter and the Cohens already
have enough repeating cage flies in
though on a pretty bad as mentally
where's the doll day that's exactly what
I want the Caliph kid riding a bad as
metal eagle to say they escaped and Dave
tries to take in the situation I've been
stuck in an urn for last ten years so by
a figurative urn of ridicule that line
of dialogue gets directed by Judd Apatow
it says hey here's a fun game I tried to
spot the moment when Nicholas Cage
actually seems invested and what he's
saying it is a prison for the most
dangerous more Dan Ian's in history or
wants to free his fellow loggerheads and
destroy the world you have a very
special gift
trick question there are no moments when
he's invested in this
it's so weird he just looks and sounds
so bored the whole movie is stunningly
to avoid a Nicholas Cage freak outs or
any energy to speak of you know how he
likes to alternate between screaming and
soft muttering here it's just soft
muttering for the whole movie
it's Nicolas Cage of a sorcerer how does
it go till we found the sorcerer who
would inherit his power focuses your
energy helps you master new spells you
have to become the prime merlinean
you're going to set me free or I'm
Nicolas Cage I know advancing in age I'm
lower and duller and lacking the rage
Nick Cage not really engaged Nic Cage
got paid my wage I like eating bread
hate taxes and taking the bills Nic Cage
he kills us all right they send all the
goblins away Nic Cage this song doesn't
rhyme Nic Cage asleep now you see this
is what I'm talking about there's no
more Nicolas Cage freak out movies
anymore I always think it's gonna be one
and it never is well you know what I'm
not going to be that gullible again
hello hello it's a sergeant slaughter no
Joe I was wondering if you want to team
up with me and devil boner in the other
room to travel to Africa and wrestle
lions until their heads explode you got
it I'll be right there
hahahaha sir got a camera hey double
boner you play one on
hey Sookie skids Dave a crash course in
the science of magic actually they do
that surprisingly a lot in this movie
everything we see is in a constant state
of vibration that's the illusion of
solidity sorcerers commiting a matter
because they're bored with capability to
use the entire power of the brain we
will the vibrations to go faster in
sorcery science or magic yes and yes no
and no when you try to shoehorn science
into magic all you do is make it less
fun for the fantasy lovers and even more
infuriating for the science nerds we
don't need to know the science of the
flux capacitor we don't need the
engineering manual for the Ring of Power
do you want me to Gloria because this is
how you get rid of Gloria's I go to
Chinatown to see if they have any that
Mulan Szechuan dipping sauce standards
they don't know so they decide to look
for the doll which they traced back to
an acupuncturist this leads to a lot of
comedic antics
hi all right that's all he could come up
will it be okay just doing do you have
an appointment
Tahoe longer okay his piss-poor
Cantonese with all the comedy we need
Tahoe like but go Rose less impressive
to our brother tried to attack oh my god
I have no idea how to train these be
still nothing babe not the birds she's
it's Susan Sarandon dragging from a
chanting look more real this is it use
the Schwartz the dragon is defeated just
as the cops show up on the scene hey
what do you got we had reports of a
Nicolas Cage movie on the loose bottle
rocket meets paper dragon in this Asian
festival between you and me cap I think
some of these folks were hitting the
saggy pretty hard
glad to know as New York is as good as
his Cantonese does he think New York is
Boston Cage takes NERP face to a safe
place to train him and he opens up the
book to open up the book the art science
history of sorcery
including our recent history as well
okay that was pretty cool yeah give him
a point
this is an island circle once you enter
there is no going back
so I should probably pee first I can
hold it in all the first time Edyta
Bruckheimer production I was teamed up
with Sean Connery what like choices
brought me here
[Applause]
you
[Music]
you know a lot of people have been
asking me recently are you Walter White
and I say yes so they ask Walter and I
say mr. Cranston they say sorry how do
you get your head so smooth well that's
the Dollar Shave Club I use the DSD
executive razor it's one of the
smoothest I've ever used and if someone
who had a lot of hair to get rid of yeah
fair amount of meat between guilty
grammar and Patrick Stewart I can tell
you it really works for a limited time
new members get their first month of the
executive razor with a tube of dr.
Carver shea butter because why would you
live in a home without something called
shea butter for only five dollars with
free shipping that's a 15 dollar value
for only 5 bucks and after that the
razor is only a few bucks a month this
offers exclusively at
dollarshaveclub.com slash awesome we all
got a shave you might as well do it at a
great price while also having it
delivered to your door just get going to
the store and hit the razors delivered
to you monthly get your special deal at
dollarshaveclub.com slash awesome I'm
Walter White not just kidding
I'm Bryan Cranston sing check out the
Dollar Shave Club today
[Music]
from the studio that brought you the
Sorcerer's Apprentice comes the next big
step in world building officer I don't
know what to say here young crier will
pussy I'll go shower out you think
you're the only sorcerer in the world
al-azhar you've become part of a much
bigger system how are you the count
conductor of the orchestra
Leopold on the land ho I'm here to tell
you about the Fantasia initiative the
Fantasia Cinematic Universe start phase
one in 2018 with Night on Bald Mountain
with Jared Leto it's turn a bog fire
tents skeletons demons skeleton demons
with their tents on fire so that's how
you're wanted on set come on second
whatever started from very weak sex toys
and in 2019 dance of the hours with
Scarlett Johansson as the ostrich I
would have dancer train to the Red Room
the graduation they're sterilized me I
can never lay another egg again coming
year 2020 Jack Black is Bacchus in the
pastoral symphony
gonna fuck another brand on y'all in
2021 Selena Gomez is the sugarplum fairy
in Nutcracker oh my god guys I am a
Barry I just well in 2022 Daniel
day-lewis returns to the silver screen
as a dinosaur in Rite of Spring and you
can't prove his under here and finally
in 2023
Bryan Cranston in breaking buck I want
abstract imagery not too big not too
specific spread out as far as the eye
can see
you know why I mean what you're crazy
god damn right they all join forces in
the Fantasia's never has there been such
a misguided franchise with so many
celebrities attached ok there's been
several but this one's especially
embarrassing
hi I'm Bette Midler let me treat you
like a dumbass by calling Salvador Dali
the melting watch back you're too early
that's for phase 2 the Fantasia
Cinematic Universe right after we
finished the Marvel Star Wars Indiana
Jones Muppets pirates and Disneynature
cinematic universes and also our new
animated films and Pixar's and like 50
live-action remakes but once we finish
our live-action home on the range we
promise we'll get around to it you're
lying aren't you yes we are so Molina
gets the help of another magician called
Drake Stone an obvious David Blaine
ripoff who apparently uses his real
magic to entertain people fun fact this
was actually the same actor who played
dr. doom in Fant for stick mom also
disappeared when I was fixing he
vanished
listen he was nothing by any Cantus and
some prescription-grade abandonment
issues I'm still taking it more
seriously here me too
cage continues to train David when high
they should go the girl from earlier
the Winter Soldier oh right right oh
this movie that was this movie
completely forgotten we all did
twenty-five minutes off screen we're
reintroduced to Bucky Barnes just call
our Winter Soldier so anyway I'll
remember sounds good and we're supposed
to just pick up where they're
non-existent chemistry left off I think
you'd better step into my cage it might
be a little crowded inside them but
there's always room for one more voice
in his head he shows how the electric
coil is one position right can actually
make musical sounds the coils are firing
at such a high frequency that sparks
literally create sound waves as they fly
through the air which is nerdy
you know he really is the poor man's
Andrew Garfield
Andrew Heathcliff over the next day when
he's going to the bathroom he's accosted
by Russell off-brand Ranma Lenny and I
you don't look like much how I'm sorry
miss this is the men's room
but cage comes to save him from both
Molina and Bora do Lander to be fair he
does use probably the films of that
sound effect oh why does that insanity
work and none of the other madness does
don't worry it's followed by a stupid
line what are you doing here Dave
working on my master's thesis what I
think I'm doing in the bathroom what l
that exposition in the opening was so
much fun
let's literally have it told to us again
tonight and kidding everything that was
said to us in the info was repeated back
to what pretty much for no reason watch
Morgana
she was making preparations something
that would enable her to enslave mankind
Merlin had three apprentices I was one
of those other kids would inherit his
power in all fairness did you even
listen in the beginning milk because I'm
sick of listening in general I'm tired
of people and will be taking advantage
of me hello this is where we're now
director Stanley Kubrick you've come
back from the dead or with Bill in the
other room you're going to shoot the
Nostalgia Critic movie on the side of
the Moon speaking of bad jokes take a
look at this fascinating we botched Star
Wars Oh Maj you don't need to see my
faculty identification come
I don't need your faculty identification
card these are not the droids you're
looking for
the lesson kids is if you can't be
bothered to think of something original
just feel something and admit you're
stealing it that's the same thing as
actual creativity kinda after we see the
dog presumably is on a Fantasia DVD Dave
realizes he has to get the place clean
for his girlfriend this is the plot now
and as you'd imagine a mere sixty two
minutes into this Sorcerer's Apprentice
remake they finally remake The
Sorcerer's Apprentice poorly fantastic
is how I would put it in Fantasia the
brooms went out of control because
Mickey was off daydreaming and not just
any daydream he was dreaming about being
a god controlling the cosmos altering
the fabric of reality the suit is every
whim I don't like the real Mickey Mouse
come to think of it what is Dave off
doing while this flubber dance is going
on showering and brushing his tongue
whimsical yeah it's a little ironic that
Mickey used magic to be lazy with his
chores while Dave is using chores to be
lazy with his magic commands you to stop
wow that line Rita was so bad it stopped
the whole movie even that spray bottle
is like I'm Windex and I could have read
that line better
Oh what the shadow of him with the axe
they're so similar I can barely tell the
difference I think that isn't done right
in the original it was intense like a
frigging horror film
he just wailed on that thing until
there's nothing left here it's just slow
random and dull
[Music]
so the Mickey Mouse cartoon is actually
more intense than Manila stage movie
what is world gage comes to save the day
making us realize if you cut the
Sorcerer's Apprentice scene out of The
Sorcerer's Apprentice absolutely nothing
would be lost from the story but look he
had something pointy on his head how
often tidge this whole scene is like
when a little kid retells a joke II
heard without understanding what made it
funny this must not happen
Gabe sends the Winter Soldier away but
for some reason she is in no way
bothered by this do you really think
that one box day was gonna make me hate
you forever you can just replace all her
dialog with so far it support support
originally this was her standing are you
afraid of heights hell okay
trust me thank God yeah no I mean I
dunno I could piss myself a time
simultaneously do you remember when you
drew King Kong in the bus window and he
lined up with the Empire State Building
you saw the world in your own way I am
trying to find some reason to be
attracted to you but Molina ambushes
cage and takes the doll from him it's
lighter than I remember so the source
material but Dave returns and they chase
down the villain to get the doll back
what the heck is this she turned into a
Mars Attacks Martian the villains escape
and realize they need reinforcements to
win so they bring another friend to life
to kidnap Dave's girlfriend I said I'd
like to make arrests okay this might
work yeah new characters kind of creepy
and badass either I need your power to
free Morgana I just don't need you oh I
didn't even see how she kidnapped the
girlfriend or use any magic or want
anybody off critic critic critic they
had to use that time for more important
scenes like what command you to stop oh
yeah cuz that got a big laugh Gabe tries
to get the doll back while Molina
watches on
come on Dave you know the drill
give me what I want and I'll let her go
you've seen this done in a million
movies we're not very original for this
will be a million-in-one violence
give me Merlin's ring and the grim old
told me the idol I saw you do it yeah of
course hands it over and Kate realizes
he has to take this on by himself no one
knows how much time they have to be with
the people they're the most important
enjoy I have no idea what I'm talking
about
they had time days
oh wow this build is just full of people
I forgot we ran in it I'm still waiting
for them to cut back to the disgruntled
army general the Olympic gymnasts
fighting for the girl's affections and
the CGI giraffe voiced by Larry David
none of those were in this movie but for
a moment you thought they might be this
is really dangerous I want to come with
you
you're sexy huh paedon Elfie has a voice
as fragile as a Faberge egg but could
you give him a slightly cool line say
sexy move over Tobey Maguire we have a
new I hunch some argon is released while
still in Veronica's body and she tries
to raise all the dead sorceress to
destroy the world
I cannot raise the dead until the circle
is complete
man that is a goal centered woman no how
long have I been out or what happened
over the centuries or has Disney bought
everything by this point but cage tries
to stop them and they have well there's
only one way to put it a wizard's duel
no disappearing where the hell's that
little girl statue I got a score to
settle
you know can we get more New York
statues and on this I want to see
Vladimir Lenin Eleanor Roosevelt and
Balto fight to the death then we'll get
the Statue of Liberty to rampage through
the city to the tune of higher and
higher in this movie stolen enough
already haven't you learned anything
it's not stealing if you admit that it's
stealing just have Dave say hey looks
like ghostbusters - problem solved
cage gets Morgana out and for no given
reason Dave can fight her without his
ring because something-something ruby
slippers I put a spell on you now you're
gone but I'm not alone I brought a
little science with me yes the science
of a mop that can move of its own power
sighs rule
well I guess you could say the mob
cleaned up this mess so Morgana is
destroyed and oh no it looks like cages
- no no no noise not over he can't die I
just not not now gee I can't believe
they killed off the main character in a
Disney film
yeah just like Snow White and Pinocchio
and trusty and Aurora and Darby O'Gill
and Baloo and Robin Hood and chief and
gurgi and basil and the beast and Iago
and Esmeralda and Megara and Giselle and
Wally and Flynn an Iron Man and Ralph
and Anna and baymax well I for one am
shocked that's not good enough
you you said all your stupid school all
those old man shoes constantly saving me
with that look in your eyes you will
believe you're watching a movie of
course cage comes back and Dave is
reunited with this totally useless
girlfriend and they fly the Eagle to
Isengard to rescue Gandalf
[Music]
alfafa lang and that was Nicolas Cage in
The Sorcerer's Apprentice how it does
not bought one of the biggest creative
risks of Walt Disney's career has been
turned into one of the least creatively
risky movies I've ever seen the
tired-ass chosen one story is beyond
hackneyed and it's not even done well
there's no feel to it he goes from
incompetent to all-powerful at the end
like an on/off switch
sometimes there's kind of neat effects
are kind of cool acting from Alpha
Molina but that's as far as it gets just
kind of cool you know how most Disney
Bruckheimer movies are these insanely
long two and a half hour monstrosity
this feels like it was shot to be one of
those but then cut down to an hour 45 so
it still has the bloated structure of a
long ass movie which makes it feel
longer than it is not even Nicolas Cage
as a friggin sorcerer can make it
interesting
it sucks Ian cage go from awesomely good
awesomely bad to just bad and I can tell
you within averaging six movies a year
now I am NOT falling for the Nicolas
Cage hype train again maybe somewhere
down the line we'll get one of those
kick-ass performances again but until
then I am NOT being merely a gullible
hello hey it's Cory Taylor Cory Taylor
lead singer of Slipknot and Stone Sour
yet and let me guess you're in the other
room with Chester a bum hyper fangirl
black willy wonka Rob Scallon and your
son grip inviting us to go on tour on an
ice cream truck actually that's it
exactly it's cruel you buddy I'm smarter
than you think
proud of you man thank you
weird you said no oh that's a shame we
tried oh well hmm I guess we'll go into
uh
[Applause]
[Music]
what the heck is this
Hidy Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out in this week we are doing the
American brain tumor association founded
in 1973 the American brain tumor
association is the first and only
national advocacy organization committed
to funding brain tumor research and
providing information and education on
all tumor types for all age groups for
over 40 years they've been providing
comprehensive resources that support the
complex needs of brain tumor patient and
caregivers as well as the critical
funding of research in the pursuit of
breakthroughs and brain tumor diagnosis
treatment and care if you look at their
site in their YouTube channel you can
see not only how many people they helped
but that they even offer tips and advice
every Tuesday for how to cope living
with a brain tumor as well as how to
spot early symptoms take a look at the
link and see how you two can play a big
part in bringing this doing that
[Music]
you